speaking of extremes and
skepticism and new ones i can't believe
i have to say this
there was an op-ed in the new york times
that i somewhat enjoyed
i i almost want to end the show right
there before i
i don't i hate that i have to say that
but nick kristoff in the new york times
published an op-ed that i sort of
enjoyed it's about internet porn
it's called the children of pornhub
subheader
why does canada allow this company
pornhub i
guess the largest pro i think the
largest porn company in the world
why does why does canada allow this
company to profit off videos of
exploitation
and assault and the article begins
pornhub prides itself on being the
cheery winking face of naughty
the website that buys a billboard in
times square and provides snow
plows to clear boston streets it donates
to organizations
fighting for racial equality and offers
steamy content free to get people
through covet 19 shutdowns
that supposedly wholesome pornhub
attracts 3.5 billion visits per month oh
my gosh
more than netflix yahoo or amazon
pornhub
raises or rakes in money from almost 3
billion ad impressions a day
one ranking lists born up as the tenth
most visited website in the world
yet there's another side to this company
it's infested with rape videos
it monetizes child rapes revenge
pornography spy cam videos of women
showering
racist and misogynist content and
footage of women being asphyxiated
in plastic bags a search for girls under
18 no space or 14 year old
or 14 y-o leads in each case
to more than 100 000 videos most aren't
of children being assaulted but too many
are you get the point
this brings us back to a debate that
actually started last december
and it kind of split the right what to
do about
the online porn problem you had people
who
in the name of a very degraded and
shallow understanding of libertarianism
said nah porn's great george washington
and thomas jefferson would love it
they basically wrote the declaration of
independence and the constitution so
that
we could all watch videos of this
trash this wicked and debased stuff
and so we got to keep pouring no
regulations and then you had another
side saying we need to ban porn
just ban it this is obviously horrible
stuff just
ban the porn right now and this debate
ensued and
i thought both sides sort of missed the
point
it gets to a lot of our public debates
right now actually right to the top of
the show we were talking about
do you defend trump or do you defend
georgia how about
both how about you do both how about you
allow trump to pursue his legal options
and encourage him to pursue his legal
options and don't encourage him to
concede
and then how about you also try to hold
the senate by voting for those two
georgia senators
why can't you do both i think on the
porn debate
we can acknowledge there is no
constitutional right to pornography
pornography has been
highly regulated if not outright illegal
from the very beginning of the country
we all we still have laws against
obscenity we jailed pornographers as
recently as
a dozen years ago the founding fathers
made a very clear distinction between
liberty and licentiousness
okay and they did not support
licentiousness and they realize that
licentiousness like pornhub
is the opposite of true liberty that it
actually undermines liberty okay that's
that's the one hand on the other hand
from the ban porn people
i think it's also worth remembering that
conservatives are prudent
we have a practical quality to ourselves
it is not possible to eliminate lust
from the heart of man
it's also not possible to eliminate the
expressions of that lust
this is why the some of the greatest
theologians and moral thinkers in
history saint augustine
and st thomas aquinas actually defended
legal prostitution
not because they thought legal
prostitution was a good thing but
because they acknowledged that it's the
world's oldest profession
it actually predates politics just
barely i guess you might say it's a form
of politics the two seem very similar
and augustine and thomas's point
was that if you eliminated prostitution
entirely
the the entire civilization would be
convulsed with lust and so
what you had to do is regulate it you
know put put it
in one area a red light district for
instance
and treat it seriously as the danger
that it is but also recognize that it's
impractical probably impossible to get
rid of it
entirely why can't we have that
conversation i think once we eliminate
the kind of stupid idea that we have a
natural or constitutional right to look
at porn
and we also eliminate the improved and
impo impractical idea
that you can utterly eliminate porn we
can have a real conversation
which is that this is obviously a major
problem confronting the country
you've got well especially in this
generation you've got kids who have been
exposed to this young boys
from very early age they get hooked on
it it warps their brain
it warps their lives it creates an
addiction that a lot of people want to
get away from
how about you can look at the number of
people in this country
there was some study that said 93 or 94
of men have looked at online pornography
and of course the typical rejoinder to
that is
and six percent of men are liars you
know this is it basically is a
ubiquitous problem
so how about you deal with that and say
yeah this is this is bad this is
this is different than having a playboy
under your bed in the 1970s
this is the the ubiquity of it the ease
of use the the
uh stimulation of it is is a distinct
problem and then heavily regulated you
know if i wanted to go buy a playboy
down the street
i would have to go and show an id
why do we not have the same mechanism
for
online porn like like a website like
pornhub
to say we're not going to completely
outlaw the thing but you have to you
have to upload an id because
in that case it's not just saying only
adults can get it i
actually don't think adults should be
able to easily access it either it
introduces an element of shame
you have to show an id and therefore
you're saying
i am openly going to be looking at this
kind of material which is very shameful
that would reduce the number of people
who do it now you might have people
making fake ids you might have people
getting around the rules
sure okay right but
as as conservatives especially we should
know better than anybody
that you can't let the perfect get in
the way of the good you can't let
ideological purity get in the way of
practical results
you can't let these abstractions get in
the way of prudence
if you could reduce this problem a
problem that's so bad that even
left wingers in the freaking new york
times are observing it now
it's not just the church ladies you know
wagging their fingers
it's not just puritans and prudes
wagging their fingers
everybody is recognizing this is a
problem
why not arrive at a sort of prudent
solution
that that is a central conservative
insight is
prudence and i think we ought to apply
it to fraught public policy issues here
this is why i often encourage people
not to cling to ideology you know in the
way that some people
just they break their politics down into
three bullet points and they say
no liberty means that i need to go look
at porn all the time no it doesn't
obviously it doesn't
and this applies to the presidential
race too
go win in georgia go go win at the
presidential level at least try
there's no reason not to try and there's
nothing
admirable or virtuous about prioritizing
that kind of abstract purity
over practical results